wait is this part of the shoe this is
like part of the style I it's just so
dumb I would not use such a harsh word
but it's pretty stupid hi I'm Megan hi
I'm Aria and today we are guessing the
prices sneaker sneaker shoes prices of
sneakers from what I understand are way
out of hand right now for like financial
purposes I don't even bother getting
invested in that he's broke I'm broke
if you're a collector then it's even
more cuz now they do like limited
releases of stuff and then the price
just skyrockets even more all I know
about sneaker heads in general is that I
know there are certain stores here in LA
like down on Melrose where people just
line up I see like a line of feel of
waiting for shoes and I think wow today
we're guessing the retail value and then
the after market value of sneakers you
like a good game again love the games
mix is a competition you know after this
you want to get some boba maybe loser
you're freaking on I do
okay Easy's Yeezy boost 700 I wonder if
the number means anything is that the
price I'll be smart but I doubt it's not
that easy of a game crack it open I
can't even open the box so this is right
here how the Frick do you open this
fancy box is made oh these are beautiful
shoes do you know what these are not the
worst not they're beautiful wow they're
really light for a chunky shoe okay I
have to miss they a controversial
opinions I think we're on the same one
go first i think i think that most like
sneakers are horribly ugly okay don't
tell my house oh yeah I was but I'm on
the same sort of train of thought them
because I think these are not that crazy
you know what I like about these is that
they don't have that like they're not
like clogged you know they still have a
bit of sweetness to them I would
actually pay some good money for this I
think there's a lot of knockoffs of
these like with this kind of color
scheme I've seen I didn't realize that
Yeezys were adidas I thought easy was
like his own with my brand
all right but Easy's through adidas okay
149 about 250 yeah damn okay I am so
should have gone to 96 oh my god no
laughs the price three hundred dollars
of these three hundred is it's a dope
shoe the value behind the easy brand
probably makes it worth three hundred
dollars to a lot of people that's a tidy
profit I want now I sorta get why they
the waiting line actually I'm waiting
line to buy okay whatever I mean I feel
like we were like it was right in the
middle I mean - $30 that seems absurd
because it's a person buying them to
wear them at that point or you buy them
to sell them in the future yeah if I had
the money I would probably do it because
just knowing that other people don't
have them that's what makes it good
socks shoes socks shoes are very in
that's what they're called oh I like
that these are beautiful oh my girl so
this is Kawhi Leonard sneaker so New
Balance is new to the game I won't
New Balance has been around but New
Balance is not a place that people were
wearing control recently I feel it's
like architecture like these shoes of
Architects these are cool okay all right
okay I was like a trendy kind of is a
more of a design element to the touch
feel I like the colors I think of all
clean and modern I do like the white
like and this sort of gives me some
superhero vibes you went six I went for
25 I got a little crazy after the last
one
Soji right oh these are so much better
looking for so much less I agree
honestly in comparison to like Yeezy
it's because Kanye West isn't standing
behind it telling you you should pay
whatever he says I know what's hot and
what's not they really didn't make much
money off fighting they're nice I like
them because they're like yeah link to
an athlete I bet you people like think
oh I wonder if he's gonna be collector
someday oh yes I'm familiar oh here's a
shoe for you and a shoe for me a large
[ __ ] oh wait sweet Easy's again the
thing is I think they're ugly like this
but I think if I saw them on a foot with
an outfit I'd be like oh those are sick
yeah very good point on its own not the
best it really depends on the outfit
that's that wear puts together for it
honestly I think these shoes are clean
as hell
I love the issues I like the way that
they look on people's feet if that's
weird I don't know but the dope shoe
yeah Wow it feels like quality feels
expensive what about 400 no they're
worth it you're worth way more than that
Wow these have less colors and it's like
one material so that makes sense yeah
but they would be slightly less resale
I'm gonna say I know that these shoes
are very popular now I would assume that
they have made like a lot more of them
these are like so popular oh yeah get
out of here wow what listen wait these
aren't these common now I'm I mean
they're clean but not $1,000 clean the
other ones would get my money before
these would I feel like those have a
distinct look and these are I mean these
are dope I'm gonna say I wouldn't spend
a thousand dollars on these shoes I love
them but I wouldn't do it you can
understand why different colorways would
sell for different prices but the
ultimate price still does
make sense to me how this could sell for
over $1000 the 10 nike air max i heard
about these if this thing is worth more
than $200 more models I'm working with
$150 a I'm gonna laugh it's kind of
interesting and hilarious because the
shoe the style of it is very like torn
down and demolished looking and I just
think it's hilarious that you'd pay a
ton of money for to look like it's
falling apart all right well first
things first
see little off-white insignia that's on
here that means they're expensive Virgil
a blow he was the designer who started
off white he now is the head of Louie
Vuitton which I think has made him like
even more valuable and made off-white
more valuable in my personal opinion so
I would assume that these ones are a bit
pricey okay thanks for that because I
would have had no idea this is the
value-add right here at the cable tie
wait is this part of the shoe this is
like part of the style I it's just so
dumb I would not use such a harsh word
but it's pretty stupid well I really
overshot I think I feel a bit better
about the shoes now honestly I do is
that okay
fine what what I could actually afford
them do you think you found a chute
within my range you think it's a style
because I know like the the vapor masses
are like expensive no look I mean maybe
all that stuff you thought about the
off-white it's not wrong it's right
resale probably is where you're gonna
see this hype around Virgil oh hey I got
a point I told you it's cuz Virgil is
that guy so like $1,200 these sold for
12
that's absurd I'm so confused I feel
like I know less about shoes than I knew
coming in you know what I get it if
people want to spend a lot of money not
something that makes them happy go for
it I think I don't know anything about
shoes anymore
I guess if you can't get them in the
store I don't really know about it I
think that like makeup can be really
expensive obviously not the same amount
but like makeup makes me happy and it's
really expensive and this is something
that you can wear frequently and it like
makes a statement about who you are in
your fashion sense so it makes sense
that people would want to invest in that
the way that shoes look and the brands
have nothing to do with what people will
pay for shoes